now one of the biggest threats the
thalibon's new rule in afghanistan is
from another radical jihadist group isk
the regional chapter of the so-called
islamic state has battled the taliban
for dominance since 2015. the recent
suicide attack on kabul airport shows
the group's intent to strike and
concerns are growing thousands of miles
to the east about the events in
afghanistan kurdish forces in syria fear
the taliban takeover could lead to a
resurgence of the so-called islamic
state
many families say they're already living
under that threat
since his father was murdered azo ahmad
aziz has been too afraid to leave his
home
not far from here two men on a
motorcycle was shot dead for local
councilmen
he had refused to cooperate with
so-called islamic state
now azo fears for the lives of his wife
and children
i'm afraid my family will become the
next target they threatened us before my
father was killed
most of my relatives fought against is
in 2014 we were attacked by them many
times my younger brother was killed by
is two years ago
region is considered an is stronghold in
eastern syria one of many in the
province
kurdish fighters put an end to the
islamists rule in 2019
with the help of the united states
but the self-styled soldiers of god went
underground and continued spreading fear
and terror murdering anyone who dared to
oppose them
kurdish forces are fighting back here
they're practicing raids on is sleeper
cells
the aim is to keep the terrorists in
check as the number of is attacks rises
there were 18 in this province in july
alone and the taliban's victory in
afghanistan seems to have given them a
boost
that's what this kurdish commander
thinks
since the attack on kabul airport he's
afraid a wave of terrorism could spread
across syria as well
the goal of the suicide bombing in kabul
was to attract new is members so they
can regroup with more force we're
convinced this is a renewed version of
is in new clothes with new methods and
new operations and more dangerous than
anything we've seen so far not just in
afghanistan but in other countries as
well
kurdish special forces are showing their
presence on patrol
they don't want to give any ground to is
and they know its fighters come out of
their hiding places at night demand
protection money take hostages and
commit murder
this is a checkpoint at an intersection
between two villages considered is
strongholds
the guards are looking for suicide
attackers and searching for weapons and
explosives in cars even if it might get
them killed
they load up motorcycles with explosives
then they set them on fire
they plant bombs to kill us
sometimes a group of them will attack us
firing at us and then disappearing that
has happened a lot
on rates like this they tried to capture
is leaders
just a little while ago they were able
to take down a top is commander
they destroyed 120 sleeper cells in july
but more appear all the time
aziz stays holed up in his house
hoping his family won't be targeted
the much feared return of is to eastern
syria seems to be ever more likely
for more i'm joined by hans jakob
schindler senior director at the counter
extremism project here in berlin welcome
um i would like to start off by talking
about the report that we just saw the
kurdish commander there is deeply
concerned about the fact that the
taliban has now taken over in
afghanistan and what that kind of impact
will have on syria what are your
concerns
well he is not um wrong in this one i
mean obviously the taliban takeover was
a massive propaganda not just for the
taliban but also for al qaeda and both
are in a symbiotic relationship so the
competing global terror network the
islamic state has now something to prove
so we will have to expect more islamic
state operations all over the globe
including of course in their core area
in syria and iraq
i want to ask you about the
psychological impact of the taliban
victory in afghanistan for terror
networks not only in afghanistan not
only in syria not only in the region but
around the world
well this was a massive boost to the
global jihadist terrorist movement
whether it's of the al-qaeda or of the
islamic state persuasion because the
taliban achieved something that the
islamic state was not able to
successfully do to actually take over an
entire country and are now the ruling
regime so afghanistan will have a new
draw for jihadist elements from around
the globe who now
obviously because of travel difficulties
will not travel in the same numbers than
they did between 2014 and 16 to syria
and iraq but certainly in the way that
they did in the early 90s where we had
this massive terror infrastructure in
the country with the al qaeda training
what about foreign fighters we saw an
influx of foreign fighters entering
afghanistan as the u.s had already
announced that it would be preparing to
leave and as the taliban victory moved
ahead is there a concern that there
could be more foreign fighters entering
not only afghanistan but the region
oh naturally afghanistan as i said has
now developed into this propaganda hub
where the taliban allegedly not only
defeated the united states but the
entire international community opposing
them so
obviously that these travels will
continue and will increase once the
terror infrastructure that everyone
expects to re-emerge re-emerges this is
on the al-qaeda side the islamic state
isis-k side of course will always serve
as a hub for disgruntled elements um
they were a purpose-built affiliate the
only one of two purpose-built affiliates
of the islamic state which sent people
to afghanistan in 2015 to actually build
up a new structure rather than accepting
the loyalty pledge of an already
existing terror group so it's very
important for the islamic state to have
that affiliate and that affiliate will
now welcome any taliban who are not
agreeing with the power division or
whatever system emerges in afghanistan
they are already partially made up of
ex-taliban so this is the natural harbor
for them plus pakistanis plus foreigners
so there will be a growth of isis k and
there will be more attacks from isis k
in afghanistan and beyond
hans jakob schindler from the counter
extremism project thank you for your
time
thank you